Jacques chir qui recevait aujourd'hui le
président de la République ukrainienne a
été interrogé sur les rumeurs concernant
son état de santé ces derniers jours
c'est une rumeur qui concerne tous les
présidents aussitôt ajouté son homologue
ukrainien je vous propose d'écouter ce
que le président de la République a
répondu à un journaliste questionnant
une question qui concerne plus la la
France que que l'Ukraine monsieur le
monsieur Chirac monsieur le Président
comment vivez-vous actuellement les
rumeurs sur votre état de santé
merci
écoutez je vous laisse juge en tant
qu'observateur vous devez pouvoir vous
forger une
opinion